[Music]
welcome everybody
to tonight's panel discussion diversity
instead of uniformity brought to you by
br 50 within the berlin science week
2020
my name is yulika schmitz and with the
background in gender studies and as a
policy advisor on non-discrimination
and equality i was very happy to be
asked to moderate tonight's panel by
br50 br50 stands for berlin research 50
a network that since 2020 pulls the
expertise and interests of more than 50
member institutions in berlin including
those of
four major science organizations such as
helmholtz association leitner's
association
fraunhofer society and max planck
society as well as government
departmental research and the field of
private
non-profit institution and with br 50
not only the
non-universitary research institution
but also politics universities and
public in berlin have a point of contact
a multiplier
and a catalyst for current scientific
and also social issues and br 50 is
managed by a joint office
at forshanks for berlin ifau and at the
whitsett be the berlin social science
center
and br 50 is divided into four units
that are represented on today's panel
and the four units are represented by
four elected founding coordinators
professor thomas zama for life sciences
professor yota ahmedinega phd for social
sciences and humanities
professor ulrich panna for natural
sciences
and professor michael hindermiller for
technology and engineering sciences and
at the end of this event uric panel and
thomas zama representing the four
coordinators will give a short wrap-up
of the event
so before we get started let me just
welcome those of you who join us tonight
in the natural museum berlin the museum
of natural history and
to those of you watching online you know
already that this event is live streamed
so just on a technical note be aware
that when you raise a question later
your voice will be recorded
and you will have the possibility to ask
your questions via the online tool slido
so we will provide you with a link or
you can just go to
sly.do and use the hashtag br5021
and please feel free to use it already
when you see our panelists and give us
your questions so we can come back to
them later on in the panel discussion so
i would like to ask you a question and
please
raise your hand or just stand up if you
agree with the
following statement diversity management
gender equality and internationalization
have become guiding principles for
almost all scientific institutions
especially in the land so please show me
your hand or stand up if you agree
with this statement
okay that's kind of sad
i was like i was thinking about this and
i thought like at least one third
of the hands would go up okay but only
three of you raised your hands okay
even more
let's investigate how diversity gender
equality and internationalization
advance scientific progress in berlin
and for that i would like to invite
tonight's panelists on stage please
franziska emeling
as solid state chemist and heads the
material chemistry department at the
bonus einstein
foreign bomb please join me on stage
is an urban studies researcher and
lecturer at weissenzi construction
berlin please join me on stage
and ivonna cafe jessica is a doctoral
researcher at helmholtz center berlin
for materials and energy welcome and
luke de mester he is the director of the
leibniz institute of freshwater ecology
and inland fisheries the egb
welcome everybody with a nice and warm
applause please
[Applause]
i would like to invite you to
introduce yourself
and give us a little
like say um opening statement would you
like to again
yes sure yeah my name is francesca
emeling i'm from the federal institute
for materials research and testing here
in berlin
and i'm a chemist by training and let's
say from my point of view diversity is
key for advancing science so if you want
we if we want to solve
difficult problems in science we need
all the perspectives we can get they
will not be solved by a bunch of similar
looking guys let's say
thank you so much okay would you like to
add
but first i introduce myself briefly my
name is noah
work at the moment at the german
institute for
integration and migration studies being
responsible for the national monitoring
of discrimination and racism on one hand
and as well as a lecturer at the art
school and advisency my background is a
landscape architecture but i had been
working very much on
racism so i have a very specific
approach to diversity
so i think i mean it was very
interesting to see that not so many
people did raise their hand
to advance diversity we have to question
our norms
and normative thinking also how we do
research
and i think it's
important that we learn to change
perspective if we are able to see other
perspectives and then from there on we
also can re-evaluate our questions
so i think diversity is very complex and
i think in the discussion we will dig
dig deeper into that
because it's not just a disciplinary
it's also an interdisciplinary and
transdisciplinary approach and i'm
looking forward to the discussion
thank you so much
thank you
good evening everyone firstly thank you
for the invitation i'm very happy to be
here so my name is ivonna
i come from republic of macedonia and i
came to germany for my bachelor studies
which i did at an extremely diverse and
international university is the jacobs
university in bremen
then i moved in frywork for my master's
masters studies one in physics one in
renewable energy engineering and
management and now i'm doing my phd here
in berlin
in addition to my phd i'm also a
helmholtz junior spokesperson so
helmholt juniors is the network that
unites all doctoral researchers at the
helmholtz association
and through the helmholtz juniors i'm
also an active board member at the n
square network
and square stands for those of you who
maybe not have heard about it at
networks of networks it's the joint
network of
doctoral researchers in germany from all
non-university institutions that means
leibniz helmholtz and max planck so we
represent the views of around 16 000
doctoral researchers and as you know
within our network there are lots of
international and diverse doctoral
research
researchers and we are very happy about
it
and we think it's a joint opinion of us
all that diversity is the way to move
forward and to make our research not
only more successful but also more
sustainable and i think when we talk
about diversity it's very important to
understand that we do not talk about
only about individual characteristics
its characteristics of a whole group of
a whole team can be diverse
which means that we have to move away
from the idea of a brilliant scientist
you know like
just one individual and focus on the
diversity of the teams in order to make
brilliant scientific progress and move
forward
thank you
thank you
yes i'm uh lucha mester i'm an aquatic
ecologist and evolutionary biologist i'm
a belgian and i have been linked to the
university of leuven basically my
yeah most of my career i came in 2020 to
berlin to become a professor at the frey
university at berlin and to become the
scientific director of the igb which is
the likeness institute for freshwater
ecology and inland fisheries
i do not consider my myself an expert in
diversity issues but i'm a little bit of
an expert by experience on one
dimension at least that's being
international being heavily involved in
science here and then sort of being
confronted with the the little obstacles
that we
experience and in addition of course as
a director i'm involved in developing
guidelines and policies to promote
diversity and inclusion
on the statement with respect to how
diversity advances scientific progress
um i would think i would see both the
global and a local dimension globally i
think it's it's a it's an absolute
important
issue to exchange best practices and you
can do that by having diverse groups
that come from different um areas work
together and then share expertises and
bring them back to their own countries
or simply exchange
and locally of course it we all profit
from the same phenomenon but also
diversity is basically a highly
enriching thing so broadening the
perspectives both with respect to the
kind of questions we ask with respect to
the approaches we take and with respect
to the solutions that we can come up
with based on our science i think so
that would be the statement yeah thank
you so much um for your introduction and
the short statement so i think it's
pretty clear that tonight's panel
discussion
will not so much be a controversial
discussion about whether diversity in
science is desirable or if there are any
hurdles that needs to be tackled but i
think we should rather as you just said
focus on best practices on exchange
knowledge on how to
like
get diversity into action and maybe
before we do that um
let us begin by explaining or as you
said digging a little deeper into how
diversity advances
scientific progress
so maybe
some of you would like to start by
giving an example or shed light on that
question
yep
i can start um
yeah
so
i i think for science first of all
diversity means cultivating talent
when you
attract diverse groups you attract
diverse talent and that is very
important nowadays i think because
we are facing some of the biggest
challenges that humanity has faced i
mean name for example climate change one
of them
so you do not have one solution fits all
you need diverse thinking you need
complex
mindsets you need complex problem
solving skills and that means you cannot
find them only within one type of a
person or one type of a group it means
you have to broaden up
and i think you know scientific research
is a group of problem solving teamwork
based on trust and collaboration so when
you try to increase diversity you are
increasing this as well you know
and i think it's very important to
actually define diversity so i think
many people are confused about what
diversity means when we talk about
diversity they think okay so it's like
the opposite of the typical image that
we have of a i don't know a ceo so for
example middle aged wealthy
um white men and the opposite would be
you know diverse but i think it comes
also down to skills not only personal
traits so we have to think about
diversity within every possible
framework you know it has to be about
ethnicity age gender social background
also studies you know uh but also things
like for example leadership skills
teamwork and things like that like
things like that and we have to keep in
mind that the loss of diversity means
loss of talent there is no data
whatsoever to support that you have a
certain type of people being more
skilled or more talented than others
therefore when you discourage or when
you systematically oppress a certain
group of people you are losing a large
pool of
of
valuable candidates and valuable talent
it's interesting for example to see in
germany that for example at university
level or for example derby tour it's
almost 50 50 when it comes to men and
women but higher up the leather you go
there are very few women so where did
all of them go right even us in our phd
networks we see a humongous amount of
diverse people but as soon as you move
on up to the system this kind of
diversity gets lost and then the whole
system kind of gets very rigid and
that's very bad because it means you
lost your talent
and also i think we have to keep in mind
that diverse teams and research address
socially relevant issues a diverse team
will always come up with more socially
relevant matters than someone who is
very narrow-minded right because you
gathered people who have such a big
overview and have such big ideas things
that you might have never even thought
of right when i talk about or when i
talk with my colleagues from another
continent or
from another different social background
i learned so much from them which means
i as a physicist and as a problem solver
i immediately get interested into new
problems into the world and i think this
is something that will push us forward
we can learn from one another when we
are diverse thank you yeah yeah thank
you for that so um we should not waste
talent right absolutely yeah and i i saw
you nodding to that mr luke demester and
we were just recently talking about
teaming up and forming diverse teams so
what is diversity to you and how is it
important to your work
yeah as i said i think and i fully agree
i think it's it to in order to think
about questions but also to think about
designs of how you would design a study
it's
the best thing to do would be to have a
diverse team of people
brainstorming about it so
so and that is more difficult than if
you're alone or with two people
but it is also more enriching so i can
only tell from my own experience i've
done a lot of research in collaboration
with ethiopian researchers
doing work in ethiopian settings and
that broadens the mind so much i mean
the type of research i did was very
different from what i do at home
but it broadened up my mind and there
were some issues like for instance algal
blooms linked to climate change that i
now view in a totally different context
than
how i would have perceived them if i
would just look at basically the belgian
or the german situation
so also with respect to solutions and
stuff like that it makes you think much
more
broadly
so i would perhaps add i'm not a
specialist at all but
so i i would guess like in medical
sciences
i mean sex and
ethnicity linked diseases or responses
to medication is actually a big issue if
you only have men
looking at it they may perhaps not even
think of including enough women or
including enough people from different
ethnic backgrounds in the studies so
these things are really important and
it's only because you have the adverse
groups that these issues come up
actually yeah yeah so uh diversity in
the research design but also
regarding the people you have in mind
you do the research for yeah yeah
exactly
would you like to add on that
yeah
i would like to add in that way
that
it's
good to have a diverse range of people
but i think the next question is
are the people who we want to be diverse
in the teams are they there
and then i think we're getting to a
structural questions also if we talk
about science and academia and where i
think we particularly focus on
germany and europe
then we have to ask ourselves how is the
accessibility to get into the university
programs not only gender but also regard
to other
dimensions also questions of disability
and able bodies and so on
and so then we also have to reflect the
questions of inequality
and how diversity and politics of
diversity do respond to these questions
yeah maybe adding on this we all i think
we all agree that diversity is important
um but we also all know that diversity
is not easy to achieve so it's really
really difficult
um and we can we can tell so maybe all
of us would say oh we have a diverse
team but there are people missing for
instance from china or the us or
whatever
and and therefore i think it's important
to have although
examples and role models to create an
awareness um how you can really get into
this diverse scenario starting from
maybe
really universal uniformity in the
beginning
yeah yeah that's important and i think
maybe before we we do that step and look
for good examples we should paint a
picture for the audience because i think
many of you can relate what are the
problems what are the problems
international researchers
or people coming from different
backgrounds face when they want to work
in science academia or do their research
well maybe as the
person
who is now in a phd phase and who has
spent maybe her
um university and master studies in
germany and comes from a non-eu country
for me always the biggest hustle is the
bureaucracy in germany i mean
getting a residence permit
in germany and then constantly renewing
it it's it's such a pain honestly and i
think the people who are hiring do not
have this enough
in their minds i think this somehow
needs to be
simplified so i can share for example an
interesting story so i got recently
extension of my phd contract because of
covet and all of this there were some
delays
i think unsurprisingly and then i had to
go to the outlander further to extend my
residence permit and then they see the
contract and i tell them but is it
possible that maybe after this deadline
you give me like at least three more
months because uh the thesis will go
into a review process and then i have to
defend and this usually doesn't happen
sooner than three months and then the
lady tells me um yeah well i can't trust
on your word i mean this contract says
to them so you're gonna get your
residence permit till then so now it
means that in the most stressful months
of my thesis when i have to write and
submit i also have to somehow find a way
to bring a proof to the outlander herder
that i yet need to like defend and that
i'm still allowed to stay in the country
so that they don't like kind of kick me
out before my defense and i think it's
often overlooked how much stress this
causes especially for for internationals
i mean this has nothing to do right
whether you're male or female it's just
simply about the fact of like
where you were born
right so someone decided that um because
you have no new passport that you have
to go through all of these
hurdles and there is not really much of
a support i think many of the of the
centers or of the institutes of course
they tell you here you need to go this
is what you need to do for your visa and
so on but we talk about equal conditions
but it's not really equal when someone
can fully dedicate to their work and
someone else has to go through this
right so then actually equality it's not
the thing that we should be talking
about it's equity right
so because you might give to everyone
equal conditions but some might still be
at this advantage and i think this is a
big hurdle and then of course you have
the the language but at least i'm in the
privileged situation situation that are
working on extremely uh international
institute where almost everything is
available in english and my colleagues
and all of those are open for that uh
but i think the the system and the
bureaucracy germany can be very very
painful with its bureaucracy i must say
even for germany
even for those who are familiar with the
language and i think it's well it shows
something that
many of like foreign researchers know
the german word ousland
yeah that should not be the case okay
and you see my german is not that good
but i say austin never heard they're
perfectly well yeah yeah yeah okay and
when we talked before this panel you
shared a story on bureaucracy or written
words in english or german so maybe you
want to share your story of the first
day as a director at igb and how yeah
this was
addressing me yeah i mean i would fully
agree again with what you're saying and
so i i mean i'm come from a cultural
background which is very similar to
germany so in principle my step was not
at all big
but i do not speak german and in the
meantime i understand it
a bit
um but um
i mean germany is a large country and a
huge language block and and so
a very rich cultural background
philosophers scientists and so there is
a big pride and therefore everything is
in german
and so it is actually
much less bilingual than for instance in
belgium if at the university all our
messages in belgium are in two languages
because we do not ex
assume that people know flemish
and so and that's not the case in
germany not always at least the case and
at igb in the meantime everything is
bilingual even the newsletter every week
is always bilingual and it's a matter of
international visitors students early
career scientists and even the director
to feel welcome if in an institute that
actually you can understand what is
written and what is so my story that i
shared is basically that i arrived as
the new director at the institute and i
could not get in because i couldn't
understand how the phone worked on the
bell because it was only in german and
and the way it was formulated i couldn't
find it out and so luckily there was
somebody passing let me in and then i
was then that could start my day
and it's sort of a little story but it's
sort of i mean i i mentioned it and
immediately then now there is a
bilingual uh thing and i think it's very
important that as
a person coming from elsewhere or from a
different ethnic background or or
whatever you mention those things
because it's not intentional it just
overlooked because people don't don't
realize it
i had two other i mean i also want to
stress that german is a very difficult
language to learn i'm older than most of
you here and so my skills to learn new
languages are limited
um i'm i'm not a language wizard at all
so and i find it very difficult and even
if you understand it then still
reading letters is a drag
and secondly
even if you do understand it and then
people are making strategic decisions
in their own native language and you
have to defend your point in an
in your second language you are at a
huge disadvantage
so any discussion you would have any
brain story would have you would always
be at a disadvantage because you would
not
say what you want to say because you
can't find a word so you cannot
formulate it as convincingly etc etc so
those are all small details but they
actually matter a lot
in your in your feeling that you have if
you're at an institute
the i had written down two other things
i mean
obviously i also indicated
administration so the german system is
very heavy on administration it was a
little shock for me also coming from
belgium
and
and rather inflexible i would say and
it's not only i mean at the at
in the science context of course it's
the whole society yeah it's it's
everything if you want to
you need a german bank card or you can
almost not survive in germany and so
that's very strange because i mean we
have european bank cards so why do we
need german bank cards etc etc it's a
sort of a
very long list so in order to solve that
it would be very important that research
institutes that there is people actually
welcoming international students and
welcoming international visitors and
helping them because they have done it
before and so that there is sort of self
help clubs or something like that
and the third part is
is a service orientation it's it's
something that i
noticed that is a bit different in
germany compared to for instance in
belgium but probably also in some other
cultures sometimes germans assume that
you know
so you you you say they say okay you
take the train and then and then that
and they do not give you the details how
to buy a ticket how to check
stuff and they sort of assume that you
know and then people have to find out
themselves it's possible to find it out
yourself that's not the issue the point
is you feel a little bit less welcome
than if people actually explain you
every single detail so a sort of a
service orientation to really say well
this is how we do things in germany then
you do this then you do that then you do
that then you do that
and having guidelines like that would
actually help a lot for any
international student i think yeah yeah
so you pointed out um and you mentioned
that before the feeling
of being welcome or not and like the
invitation of your research your opinion
your voice matters
so we
yeah yeah i mean i just wanted to add
it's not i mean that's the the
perception of the person who might be
involved but the other thing is of
course that in discussions those people
will not speak up
and and and therefore their voices is
not hurt and so you you you almost have
to rearrange a little bit to make sure
that those voices are hurt yeah yeah
okay
let me i'm trying to bend over to our
researcher
how can we work on that how can we make
feel like people feel welcome or invite
them to to voice their opinions
i'm looking at you
you were looking at me yes yeah i was i
was i was a little bit thinking about i
think
because we were talking about diversity
and and to make space more welcoming and
i think language is a huge part of it
but at the same time while i was
listening i was like but this is not
enough
this is
it's important but this is not enough to
really gain diversity and when we had
also a pre-conversation we were also
talking i mean as i said before also
about structures because
i mean
i'm a scholar i want to make up a career
but if we look at who can make up a
career then we have to ask ourselves
some hard questions who can follow up to
make a career
and
we were also talking about that gender
is not only having more women on leading
positions but this as well
is something about
and so
beside feeling more welcomed
but
speaking personally for me which is not
welcoming to me is the vision of site
for tracks gazettes we just had this
campaign ich bin hana
and
so this is not welcoming for me because
there are huge hurdles to make up a
career and being part of a
growing diverse team and not just for a
short time or for a specific phase in
the career because
if we think through diversity we have to
think through
students
phd
postdoc
and senior and so on through all career
steps and
so going through that
we see that
in particular in germany
when it comes when i look at the numbers
of more women of leading positions and
becoming professors
the progress
is quite slow and although i don't think
we should discuss diversity only on the
gender dimension it's too complex but
just looking at this one it shows how
long it takes to really strange uh
change um
the the institutions because
if we want to
um create knowledge we want to produce
knowledge
and you said we shouldn't lost talents
but i think it's not only about losing
talents it's also about to advance our
understanding what is it what we see and
what do we need to learn to get
to ask the new questions and to make
progress in there and
this goes beyond
gender and backgrounds but also in the
international level not just in europe
but also in a global perspective like
who has access to what kind of journals
like
besides visa and residence permits it's
not for everybody in a global
perspective easy to travel to go to
conferences i mean we might see changes
in the upcoming years because after
pandemic i see
that the whole
system how we travel to conferences
might change but until now it is very
much centered about the global north
and if you look into projects which go
north south
it's very much
complicated there is a structural hurdle
because the money is
coming and from the northern hemisphere
and sending their scholars but inviting
scholars from the south
to europe or the u.s
it's really problem beside
either those countries they can bring
their own funding
budgets
and also residencies and so on so um
i was a bit like
language yes it's important but it's in
the later phase right there is a a lot
that comes before i think like
i don't think it's either or it should
be always there i mean as uh as it was
said it could be an easy change to just
have a bilingual so why isn't that
always happening this is i think it's
easy but i wouldn't stop there and say
okay this has to happen for sure and
then there are further steps to take
so we've heard many obstacles already
like language bureaucracy administration
service orientation
vision shaft side gazettes and all the
structural hurdles and you mentioned the
like let's say commitment to learn
commitment to to face the problems we
are facing right and um maybe we can
switch a little bit to what does help
what do you know um helps or what do you
see what is already in place that may be
focusing a little bit more on gender
like network networks what what helps
like especially women to advance in
science
maybe
for emma ling
yes
i just wanted to say because luke
mentioned this um welcoming attitude and
and the start in a country so let's say
in our institute we have an
international office now in place who
would really help
um students to get these first steps
done also the all these bureaucratic
hurdles and that is like a little thing
to do and it has a huge effect before
actually other scientists would take the
new phd students around to to visit all
this auslan never heard
places and so on so but coming back to
your questions yeah we have in other
words we have a network in place it's
called lana
it's a ladies and network um in atlas
wolf and we we do mentoring on different
levels also different stages in the
career
i have mentees and and i also had a
mentor so that is possible
and we have courses and trainings but
but usually i think
not the women need so much to be trained
but it would be better to train the
other half of the population males need
to know how they could handle the story
and help women as a let's say as a
bystander on their way to advance their
careers
yeah so it takes everybody to achieve
equality what else does help what do you
know what do you experience of like
helping internationalization and
diversity and academia
me again yeah um no i i i wanted um
yeah to
to to agree on on
these issues that you mentioned and also
on the
hurdles before actually coming because
this is this is something that i was
indeed not highlighting but this is
from an international perspective and
from a perspective on different national
backgrounds and and
i would even say it's not only this it's
also so socio-economic background within
germany i mean so there is already an
issue that we basically don't have
enough diverse students
going to our university so that is
something that we as institutes can do
little about ex except complaining about
it
[Music]
but um
so for instance we at igb we
really want also to attract for instance
postdocs from global south this was one
of the things that i wanted to to create
but if you do that by just having of
our igb fellowships open to everybody
and then select it's a very difficult
decision to sort of say well you have
somebody with an extremely good cv and
then somebody with somewhat less good cv
coming from the global south and to
compare them
and so
we have now decided to um to try to
enlarge our postdoc fellowships and to
actually have a postdoc just only for
people from the global south so that you
can compare them amongst them because
indeed the access to libraries the
access to resources the access to
to uh
even education is different and so what
you then have to screen is the capacity
the potential rather than the number of
papers or something like that
and so i think these things you can do
they all cost money i mean we also have
to realize that
it's not that this is all for free
um but these are sort of things that
could cope more or less with with what
you're mentioning at least for to have
people from global south or from
underprivileged areas globally basically
[Music]
so yeah that's probably my contribution
here is there a network where you share
experience on how to become more diverse
or how to become more international in
in balloon d do you like learn from each
other you know
well there is this emerging initiative
now within br50 of course on the
internationalization and within the
forcing wound uh of course we have a
little bit of experience that we can
exchange and we are developing
guidelines for diversity and we're
discussing those at this moment so but i
think br50 could play a very big role in
there
and who's contributing is there like
because i'm trying to to like paint a
picture because you have like gender or
equality
hats within a unit do you have like a
person
who is committed to
internationalization in the institutions
or do you do it as a director or
maybe no we don't i mean
we are not a huge institution so it
depends also on the size of the
institute how many of these officers you
can have
but what we do have and which is
really great actually we have a sort of
a grassroot
initiative which is the
diversity and inclusion group
who are simply scientists and
science support staff that's from
diverse backgrounds that sit together
and actually sort of
discuss about any
issues about diversity and
internationalization and also bring this
to to our attention yeah and so so this
is also one way to do it is that you
have a sort of a self-organizing group
basically and i think that's actually
wonderful that people do that yes
i would like to add also because you
were asking in terms of best practice
well i'm not such a huge fan of sharing
only backed prestige best practices but
as we were talking about
internationalization and i was um
also thinking what happened after 2015
and i think there was a major kind of a
major change in terms of
internationalization because many
refugee
students came to campus and so
universities were opening welcome
centers and also having all these
programs scholars at risk programs and
and this is really like
advanced career scholars and bring them
to the german
academic system and there i see a lot of
conversations
how that could do not in terms of
internalization in terms of having new
corporations who can cooperate along
which questions and that i think is
shaping a more welcoming culture at the
universities so i mean i i watched it
and i saw it at the taylor dresden when
i was working there but also in berlin
the several universities were setting up
specific programs and i think i think
that programs doesn't have only an
impact for the so-called targeted groups
being refugees but for all international
students on campus making
legal knowledge accessible and
i mean all the questions you have when
you come in as a young student so
that i wanted to share here as well
yeah thank you
i would like to kind of connect to some
of the things that were already
mentioned um and i think the first thing
is i mean we are already in a very
privileged position because we are
already like higher up in the letter so
now of course it's maybe easier to talk
about like
diversity and how we can increase it but
it starts much earlier right i mean it's
also i think this is also a bit what uh
noah was mentioning uh that you do not
give equal opportunities to everyone
from the very start right so i think we
also have to understand the diversity
it's kind of like a cyclic process it
doesn't end when you hire someone and
you say okay i filled in this i checked
this
box you know i have this diverse person
but you have to understand that you like
have to keep on going back and forth
understanding what is now needed next
what can you do to improve it if you
have this one person how can you
encourage this person to bring more
people from like whatever background
they are coming from right because you
have to promote diversity also as a form
of inspiration right because you don't
want it to just end as soon as kinda it
happens because you want to end up
actually changing things bottom up right
i mean any kind of biases start early on
they didn't all of a sudden appear when
we were 30 or 40 or phds or directors so
it means that like we are systemically
discriminating or discouraging either
certain groups of people or individuals
or countries doesn't matter i mean just
take open access as an example right i
mean if you want to have access to
journals it costs a lot of money i mean
naturally
institutes or universities in poorer
countries will not have this access as
someone in germany right so of course
now it's questionable how much one
country can
mix or fund in into another and things
like that
but you you have to understand that one
of the best practices is to tackle
problems early on you cannot like start
talking about them when we are already
hiring phds or professors although and i
agree for example about with the
short-term contracts this is for example
a big cause of loss of diversity just to
share some statistics in our surveys for
example 70 percent of the phds say that
they do not find academia attractive
precisely because of these short-term
contracts 92 percent of the people that
are under 45 and in academia have
short-term contracts by the time they
get their full professorship they had on
average more than uh six short-term
contracts and it takes them more than 10
years to become full professor
most of the people from diverse
background they're like i'm out of this
you know i i don't want to deal with
this right it's too much
right so you have to keep on changing
the system and you have to do it in a
cyclic manner once you change something
you have to track back how it happened
you have to adjust you have to be mobile
not rigid rigid systems will kill
diversity
yeah thank you for that
please use the opportunity and send me
your questions via slido um so it's sli
dot do and then you use the hashtag
br5021
and if you have a question here in the
audience um we will
come to that in some minutes and i would
like to end this first round with asking
you about the first steps what are the
most important steps that need to be
done in order to
tackle the hurdles and promote diversity
so maybe
each of you at least one step maximum of
three who would like to start it
maybe if we take up ivana's example so
what she explained with a visit at the
outlander we heard is that there isn't a
lack of awareness how an academic career
actually proceeds and how the time
scales are you know handing in the uh
the thesis then there is time before you
have the defense so there is a lack of
knowledge on that side
which
puts a lot of pressure on her in this
case and it i think it would be super
easy for everyone to to draw let's say a
timeline how this usually works
that could also be handed to to some
administration and and to make it just
clear and and i think as a
as a
director of an institute or you you
could also sign that that it's the
natural way so it's a really an easy
step and it would make the life of many
of our phd students and also postdocs
much easier
first steps most important step
that needs to be done right now
on a political level or institutional
level or structural level
i will i will just try i mean i find it
very difficult to say the first steps or
other steps honestly i mean there is a
whole lot that needs to be done
um i would have um i would i would say
two things um the second thing is not a
step by the way but the first thing
would be i mean try to raise awareness
at all levels and and sort of um
i do think that you basically cannot
have enough workshops and and and
trainings and lectures on these issues
to make people
aware of it and so and and that means
both scientists and science support uh
people so what is for instance
uh for international students again in
terms of language also important that
there is language courses both ways i
mean the international people learn
german and local people learn english
and so
because
any communication goes smoother and
therefore people will understand each
other better and all the prejudices will
be
reduced
um as a hopeful signal i would say i
mean we have a long way to go but as a
hopeful signal i would say that this is
a problem that solves in the end itself
once you have enough people from
different backgrounds then you will
always have more and more indications on
how to do it better and then this this
then the prejudices will disappear
because it's really interesting that
prejudices are especially important if
people have never
encountered
people from other backgrounds
and and so if you have a diverse group
then you see that actually things go
very smoothly and prejudices are gone
and and sort of things are are
can be very harmonious whereas in the
beginning everybody's a bit afraid of it
that's the hopeful signal yes yes i
think we could um yeah dig a little
deeper but let's stay with the steps
that need to be taken
anything to add
i think
i would also share that raising
awareness is important but not only on
the individual level what every
individual level
or person can do in terms of learning
more and so on but i was just thinking i
mean we do have more diversity
management or diversity offices in
universities but to have a structural
analysis of
what is accessible or inaccessible and
then from there on to rethink what could
be changing within
little programs in the larger
organization and to make it an or a task
of the whole organization which is not
addressing just individuals and offering
workshops but also to rethink their own
structures and what could happen and i
think there are many many many ways to
go and it's hard to decide where to
start
but to raise awareness in terms of also
to raise awareness how these structures
create
uniform teams
in that regard yeah
i can also add up some things um
so i i think firstly from a phd point of
view i think it's very important to
discuss the contracts and what is really
going on with germany with these
short-term contracts and the the
pressure that is causing i do think that
this is a
this is something that can be changed
and it should be discussed more and it
should be on the long term be changed
because i don't think that academic
career in other countries is so tedious
as it is in germany that's the first
thing but the second that i also think
it's often overlooked uh and it connects
a little bit to the point that was
mentioned that the problem will solve on
its own uh it's actually the so-called
in-group favorism during the hiring
processes so i was read reading recently
an interesting story about a person who
used to work
at harvard in the astrophysics
department and they they were through
the hiring process you know and like
admitting also students or or employees
it didn't matter and he said but every
time when we would review our
applications the best ones were always
from men
you know and then uh one colleague also
academic woman told him you know maybe
what you actually have is in group
favorism namely that you are favoring
the candidates who are similar to you so
even though you want to do something
good you actually end up
being guided by unconscious biases and i
think this is important to point out
because not every discrimination or lack
of diversity is done on purpose not
every group or every person is sabotaged
on person
on purpose it just means maybe that the
people who are into the recruiting
process are not diverse enough so i
think also the recruitment team should
be diversified
and i think
this can slowly move on move us away
from the unconscious biases if you leave
early on to have a hiring process or
hiring team that it's not diverse they
will not hire diverse people or at least
they will hire at the lower degree you
know and this will kind of cause a
ripple effect and it will make it like
being so postponed that
actually we will even forget what
diversity was right so you have to
actually work actively and since we were
also talking about best practices i
would like to share something very close
to home so to say it was something that
happened at my center so at home centre
in berlin
we made something called diversity audit
so the center invited everyone to to
share
every employee regardless in which rank
or what kind of contract they have
what they want to see at the center or
what diversity is for them and then we
kind of pinpointed two topics that kept
on repeating you know or that were
important to the people in our center
and we kind of formed like task forces
and now the idea is that each task force
addresses different points of like
what were brought in the audit
and we also even had things like for
example conflict management or mental
health and someone might ask how is this
about diversity but if you think about
it people who are not who are somehow
diverse into their teams actually they
experience also so much more maybe
mental health struggles right because
they might not fit like feel like they
fit or they're like other bureaucratic
things that bother them so it means that
these are small steps that institutes or
centers or companies can do just
approach your people and ask them
you know without liking an open
atmosphere what they want to see and
then commit to it right it's all great
that we talk that it's important but at
the end if you do not commit to it you
don't really move forward right so i
think it's very important to take a
stand and to actually commit to put
these changes into place
yeah thank you for that so um
i plan to open the stage now for
questions but i would rather prefer to
direct this point directly at you and by
asking
you
do you work in a
let's say do you work in academia show
me your hands if you work in academia
somehow
okay okay
do you have teams or people
dealing with
internationalization you know of within
your institutions if it's a yes
okay okay so do you take a stand do you
as you just said um
do you say
what you want and what is needed
okay
so
for for for those of you joining us uh
via the live stream um
i saw like two hands when i ask whether
you take a stand this might be because
of the background because you don't need
to take a stand but as we learned
equality equity and diversity is not
only a matter
of those who feel excluded but it goes
both ways okay so thank you for that
please use your opportunity now and
raise your hand if you want to ask a
question we have a microphone there or
if you want to make a comment or add on
what we've heard please feel free to do
so right now
just show me your hand
so what question i have is um
we've seen in norway for example that we
had a cabinet which was more women than
men
so if we asked how the scandinavian
countries changed
the gender equality at least it was the
quota
right so it was clear quota that for
10 15 years
in sweden in norway
in denmark you had clear
guidance that every board had to be at
least
50 or starting with 30
40 50 percent women so what do you think
about it i mean this is some
big discussions there are
arguments for it there are arguments
against it
do i only get the job because of the
quarter and all these questions what
what is the
position of the panel
thank you
yeah
the quota
who feels
i can say yes please
um
i mean there's two ways to have quote i
guess something quota in appointments
and quota in in boards and evaluation
panels
if it's only in evaluation panels and
boards you have to actually have a
little bit of uh awareness that it may
also have a negative effect on those
women who are actually appointed so we
try to on the one hand we try to enforce
it on the other hand we try to be very
sensitive to that because on the in the
end women are not doing anything else
and being on boards and have to be
present everywhere and then they can not
invest so much time in their science
which is then
again not very positive so this is not
easy
[Music]
my gut feeling would be so
in terms of appointments
with respect to post-docs we were now
also thinking do for instance say well
if we have three postal positions two
have to be women and and and stuff like
that
i would sort of say
at the beginning you should
try to follow
i mean to be very aware of it and to
have very diverse selection panels etc
etc and if you see that it actually
doesn't advance
then in the end the only way will be
quota
i think then yeah
that's that's then the end conclusion
it is easier for gender by the way than
for any other group so that's another
thing that you can you can think about
does the panel agree or
different takes on the quota
yeah i mean i do agree i think we we do
think that we can make it by ourselves
because there are good arguments for
diversity and it shouldn't be such a big
deal to change it but if we look at the
numbers
and as you were referring it took about
10 to 15 years so at the very first
moment it starts it's hard
but on the longer term
and that is a political question because
then you really have to admit that you
failed and that because of that failure
you have to
come come in with politics of quota
and
in terms of gender equality i think it's
a bit easier because this is much easier
to have the data and then to look okay
either it's board or hiring process on
the positions and so on
but when it comes to other backgrounds
and when we also look on people with a
migration background or questions of
racist discrimination
then it gets really hard to get those
data because in particular in germany
it's very hard to get this kind of
equality
data there are first data sets which are
going but it's not still there in the
universities
so um
from and also from our own experience
also in smaller organization
um when you set a quota
it's taking a stand because it it forces
you to look out for the people who
you're missing in your board
organization and so on and so it's
i think it's it's a good and sustainable
way to change the organizations or
whatever unit we were talking about
yeah
i want to read out a question coming
from the chat to you
do you have advice for people from
minority communities who want to be a
game changer
hands on
how to become a game changer when coming
from a minority become many game
changers
this is my first advice i think it's
important to to come together to form
groups and collectives and support each
other
and then
it's much easier to take a stand
wherever you go and are
and
and look out for other peers and people
who may have the same experience and
from there on
go
try and change the game but not to
invest the idea there are only
individuals who can change the game
i would also add that
probably if the person is already asking
this then they're thinking about
changing the game which means maybe they
have a bit at least of the change uh of
the chance to be the game changers and i
think it's just very important to
believe in what you want to be changed
and in what you perceive to be your
personal mission and to just be
be brave you know i mean there will be
many obstacles on the on the way because
these are unpleasant maybe things
sometimes that we are discussing or
sensitive issues and so on but i think
it's very very important to have these
game changers you know and i think once
the this person starts picking up and be
brave
they will meet more support and with
time this can grow into a community so i
think this um believing in your personal
mission and being brave
is very important if you want to be a
game changer right
yeah
perhaps perhaps i cannot
i i i'm not sure but i think it would
work better if you do it in a
multidimensional way
and so that you actually have diverse
group or that you are
team up with diverse group and that it's
not only about one dimension of
diversity that you try to achieve
the other thing is i would think
i would hope but i actually also think
that most people are actually of
goodwill
and and many of the things are actually
because people have not thought about it
or didn't see the obstacles or the
barriers so
i think at least in the beginning the
best way forward is to be very
constructive and to come up with
suggestions and say well this is what we
observe what can be done about it etc
etc i'm not sure if you keep on hitting
a wall whether you have to keep being
constructive that's that's something
different
but i do think that sometimes people
immediately think oh and this is this is
intentional racism or this is
intentional discrimination sometimes
it's not and sometimes it's a barrier
that people don't see and
try first the constructive way and and
and try to team up with others who feel
the same way and change things
yeah
okay regarding the will and the
unconsciousness i have two questions i'm
going to read out the two questions and
you can just answer to the one
um you relate with so
dora asks as a director of a team is
there a good way to prepare people to be
more inclusive or to be ready to work
with more diverse especially in
diversity sorry especially in science
that's the first question and the second
question is how can we foster cognitive
diversity within a field beyond
diversity based on external factors like
gender age nationality to enable more
innovative science
maybe to the first point
to raise awareness for diversity i think
we have covered it somehow
already these unconscious bias issues we
we all carry along with us there are
there are tests out there where you can
test your blind spots and it's super
telling so um i was
it was also telling for me um
these are tests you can take online and
they
they bring this new perspective so you
think i'm absolutely clear diversity is
the goal and then you realize oh there's
a slight undercurrency of racism in a
certain direction so this can be really
an eye-opener and i think that would
also help these um what we see these
very uniform panels you see from time to
time also in politics and they are not
aware that there is a let's say a person
of color missing or a woman missing they
just like happy in there we look all
alike situation and and this little
test they take about 10 minutes they can
help a lot i think
you could
you could also do self tests i mean i i
i remember that when i was panel a
member of a panel of erc
that then
they for instance you had to rank 35
proposals or something like that and at
the end they showed off every panel
member the scores from men and women and
they did not say that we had to make
them equal they just said well think
about it if they are an equal think
about why they are an equal check how
you made your decisions and stuff and
you can you can do that for everything
you can do that for every person you
hire you can basically screen that for
yourself and say well okay these are my
statistics uh what do i do with it
and as an advice to that team leader i
would say
confront them with diverse teams
send them out to diverse teams or or or
have workshops invite a diverse team and
and let them experience it
training yeah experience basically
training by experience basically yeah
yeah yeah but i also would add that
there are also i mean there are
professional uh
there's a professional um offer to do
i don't know uh
anti-race anti-racist
kind of teaching anti-bias training
diversity
training and so on so
depending on the team and how diverse it
is or not it's also possible to get
professional people get in and say okay
if you want to do
a diversity oriented organization
development you can look at these and
these and that and so it's not just
sending out and that people do and make
their experiences nevertheless is
important
but if you have a team and you want to
work with a team and if you want to
raise awareness and also to look at your
own routines
i mean like
weekly meetings like who is speaking how
and what and so there's so many issues
how you can change us a bit of their
working culture to make it more
inclusive and to unlearn some stuff and
to relearn new stuff and
so i think it's also a good idea to
bring people who are not part of the
organization but who could get advices
who could also do kind of supervision
and that could be also helpful and in
these kind of set settings but to see
what is possible in these settings has
changed
yeah well this falls into the area of
training and leadership trainings and
when i um well take a look at my
colleagues or people i know working in
science and academia and i asked them
about their trainings
well
they are good researchers and then you
just climb up the ladder
and sometimes people they don't get
trained in let's say
skills how to work with people and not
even talking about like biases so let me
ask you who of you um has elite who of
you is like a director or a team leader
or has people working
for them okay
perfect thank you yeah okay
two of them
did
a training on and i make it really broad
okay on let's say biases gender or
discrimination show me your hand a
training on job training okay that's
half of it okay
50
okay
thank you for that so take you take your
chance and ask a question to our
panelists show me your hands if you have
a question do you want to add on the
questions i read out or
can i
uh just about the the group leaders i
from a
person who is still into position to be
let so of course to have superiors
either supervisors professors
directors of institutes and so on i
think it's always amazing also for us
when we see that the person who are in
higher rank than us are so willing to go
through such either trainings or to
increase the diversity in their teams i
think it creates a very healthy
atmosphere right i mean you feel safe to
speak with these people to speak up your
mind to share your ideas and i think
this is this is very very important i
find it a bit sad that often
workshops are addressed actually at the
minority groups so for example you have
i don't know women how to become leaders
or like
phds going through good scientific
practice and workshops and things like
that but actually the people in the
higher positions do not have to go
through as much uh trainings right and
this also causes a certain disbalance of
how to say of of
of training or even a bit of power i
would say because the people who already
reached the top they are convinced
that they are
fine with everything and sometimes
that's true but sometimes you know times
are
changing and these people need to also
be flexible and willing to learn
whatever it is right not
not only about diversity so i'm always
very happy when i hear that there is a
certain group leader who asks how can we
do this or that because already this
person um in physics we would say across
the energy barrier you know kind of like
jumped over and now out of here
everything is so much easier once you've
reached that awareness and willingness
and i think that's that's very important
and we would do
really a lot better if
every person in power asked this and
then we might not even need quotas about
women because this person will be well
aware that you have just as equally
qualified people among women even
without the quote right
do you have questions for your
colleagues do you want to comment on
something you've heard do you want to
learn
more about
a statement that one of your colleagues
made
or do you
have a question this is the last round
this is the last chance so please
show me your hand and even if it's a
comment from your own experience working
in academia
please let us know now and maybe i i
just let you know that we all must leave
this building by eight o'clock so we
will have like around 30 minutes for the
reception and i promise you this will
not be enough for each and every one of
you to ask your question individually so
take your chance now and i have yes in
addition because you were saying that
and we were also having that in our
pre-discussion about the diversity
audits
and auditing university and
to make that specifically mandatory and
binding to funding that it could be a
funding criteria that these institutions
have at least these audits because there
are several out there and i think it's a
way
i mean we could talk about
loose processes like every organization
invents by itself but auditing is kind
of standardizing but you also can review
whether it makes progress or not but if
you connect that to the question of
funding
um
i think that could be also very powerful
in terms of making change
yeah
and um do i have i actually want to
comment on something else because i
think it we are talking here about
diversity so i want to share maybe a bit
controversial opinion it's about the
quote on women um i as a woman i'm
actually not a fan of them
um
so
you know in germany specifically
no one is discussing
why
women actually
take um
like not full-time jobs you know or why
they're living and they think that quota
would solve it but it wouldn't i mean
just look at like kita places you know
i mean
the mothers want
they are put to the choice family or
career even if you put the quota you
would still have plenty of women leaving
jobs because the system did not allow
them to stay into this job
i want to live in a world where
i mean being a woman is not a big deal
we are 50 of the population okay so i
don't want to discuss about women in the
concept of diversity it's just simply
another person that you hire i want to
live in such a world you know and i
think the problem with quotas is that
women are already fighting with so much
biases and i fear that in societies such
as
germany
quotas might open more space for
discrimination and biases namely you are
here because we needed a woman you know
and sadly i have already experienced
this a bit it's it's not pleasant okay i
mean it has to be whether someone is
qualified or not and
we should have something called soft
quotas
namely for example um under the
condition that two candidates are
equally
qualified we hire the woman for example
okay that's kind of like a soft quota
but you still force your your employee
to hire the women you know and we do
have a lot of qualified women but if you
have a system that in a way
systematically step by step kicks out
the women then it's no longer about the
quotas it's simply about the rest of
your system that keeps on being built in
such a way that sooner or later they
will drop out i mean for example in phd
phase or university phase you have women
right but the more time passes by they
get like so-called time poor so they
don't have that much time so they have
to choose family or career household or
career you know okay my
kid is sick please come pick it up you
know and and things like that you know
and i think it's it's not very talked
about you mentioned scandinavia but if
you look at scandinavia also the share
of household work it's almost equal
among men and women while in germany
this is not the case not yet right so i
think you cannot really talk about
quotas as like the solution of all when
you do not look at the rest of the
system and i think this is very
important for people to understand
because it's so easy to just put a quota
and then still you will have the women
dropping out right and then you will
still have into ceos and leading
position
men which i mean i don't say that it's
like bad to to have men right but you
can have just as equally qualified women
if you allow them the system to thrive
right and if you allow them to have the
same amount of time to spend on their
jobs and exercises and when you take
into account care work not only children
but i mean you're all familiar with that
i think for me the most like um
the clearest picture i got was on the
data that in germany
more
like daughters um
not daughters how how do you say that um
i forgot the term so the
um the wife takes care of the parents of
the husband
i don't know the german german either
okay
in-laws thank you so much so more female
in-laws take care of their like
related parents um then
boys sons
take care of their elderlies okay
so as long as we work like that it's
kind of difficult to like difficult to
achieve and
right even more serious things for
example the taxing system in germany
right you have this option if one of the
people earns more into a family then
that more of the taxation goes on the
person who earns less which means if you
have woman who did not take a full-time
job she is the one that brings less
money so she will be so heavily taxed
that in the end the family makes the mat
and says but look actually it's better
if you do not work and be a housewife
and take care of the the kids and the
family then actually we're going to have
more money or what happened recently the
government says every person or family
needs to have
kita spot but they do not have enough
spots in the kindergarten so they say we
will give you money if the kid does not
go to kindergarten but then someone
needs to stay with the kid at home right
and then who stays the woman
so this is kind of like things that you
should do before putting quota you
should fix
the big holes into your system exactly
and as i think many of you know that the
covet um 19 epidemic just like
highlighted all these like structural
mistakes we have like the the rates of
um
of
women publishing papers they've gone
like down and i think this really is but
that is a and that is a point but the
the rate of
men publishing went up that is
even more scaring actually but as you
manage
mentioned scandinavia or norway um and
the quota there is a different thing
it's a cultural
issue so in in let's say in sweden for
instance um
the
mail
let's say colleagues would also be asked
why are you still in the workplace why
are not
are you not at home spending time with
the kids it's a cultural thing and it
starts
from top if you think about the first
covet
cabinet we had the small one there was
no ministry for
taking care of a family so
she was not included in this cabinet so
that there was no in sweden for instance
that was the first thing how can we sort
out childcare in this situation and that
is something yeah we have we have to
work on yeah it's a cultural change you
wanted to comment right i wanted to
comment on
saying i mean so the quarter in
scandinavia went in parallel
two changes in the society
and then
with with more quotas there were more
women also in the higher rank management
posts and said we need the keta places
we need places for women also to get
into this it was a process it was not
from one day to the other
and and i disagree that it is a problem
on the postdoc level i think our main
problem in the moment we have is really
on the on the full professor level
because i mean at least i what i see in
in biology and molecular biology that we
have on the post of level already more
or less a 50 50 between men and women
but what we are missing
is really the full professor
levels where and and i think there
we don't need soft quarter we need hard
quota we need
so now you have to hire a woman
filling this position i i really and
then i think we have a parallel
development also
all the other points which you mentioned
are completely correct but i think it
would really help
if we have the quota but maybe i outed
myself too strong now
thank you for that strong opinion and
maybe you can take it to the reception
because if we open the quota
discussion i think always the most
interesting we need two hours more of a
time
and since we are running out of time i
would like you dear panelists to
close with like just one thing
you take home
from
this panel tonight
luke demester would you like to start
well i would be hopeful at the same time
i would also i mean if you then look
indeed at these systemic issues
and i would actually like to add the
fact and i've honestly no clue how to
solve that
is the the sort of the rat race
atmosphere the negative competitive
atmosphere that
um
it's sort of essential for science that
there is critical evaluations but at the
same time this is then combined with the
fact that there is very few positions
etc etc then the systemic
issues
combined perhaps with the absence of
role models and therefore a sort of an
imposter syndrome versus a sort of the
lack of self-confidence that people drop
out and that they don't that they even
they question basically do i actually
want to do this
and and so that is a very uh sad thing
but to end up with something very
positive um i promised myself that i
would say so is that obviously berlin is
a hugely diverse city
and so
berlin has actually
if uh the policies would be adapted in
in in certain ways if these barriers
could be um could be
um
broken up
then it would be a huge diversity
actually to become a real combined zom
vision soft metropole
yes thank you
ivona
yeah so i think firstly it's a very
positive thing that we are here so it
already shows uh initiative and interest
and i think that's
a really great thing and i hope it will
it will expand
i you know i always say i'm a physicist
so i love complex problems
and diversity is one of those problems
and i am very passionate about it and i
only hope that
people like us can keep on spreading the
motivation about the diversity topic and
the interest that we have and that it
will not be any more a taboo topic and
that it will not be a scary word we
mentioned it a few times that actually
it's not always on purpose why the teams
are not diverse and i already think this
is a positive thing right as long as we
accept that we are all
prone to certain biases that we actually
did not even have control of maybe this
was something learned in our culture or
in childhood it's already a big
step ahead right but now we are adults
and we can have control of what we do
forward on you know and we can move
towards building a more diverse and
inclusive science not only in germany
but throughout the whole world and i
think it's important to understand that
this is not only about promoting and
doing good science but it's also like
the
ethically and morally correct thing to
do yeah thanks yeah
um
i i was a little bit hanging on that
there was this i think luke you said the
more diverse people come in then problem
will solve and i was a bit like i don't
think it's just about bringing more
diverse people into it i think it's
actually
the global challenges at hand will put a
lot of pressure on us to think how we
team up with whom we team up and how we
create knowledge because
we have to rethink what is this what we
can give at hand
in phase to these problems and so
i would conclude that
diversity to me actually is a process of
democratization
to make knowledge production knowledge
accessible and it's a process of
democratization and how we organize that
so it's not just about
bringing and creating and crafting
colorful pictures but
on a very systemic but also individual
level
to consider that as a question of
democracy and a process of
democratization
thank you
yes yeah okay i'm the last one so
everything was said already but i think
we should appreciate the mix and try to
bring the mix to work and as scientists
i think you usually claim that we are
lifelong learners and i think diversity
might be an issue where we still have
a blind spot and a lot to learn and i
think it's an issue we need to tackle
and but i'm optimistic about it
before i invite the representatives of
the br50
to comment
and
let us know your key lessons learned
please give a warm applause for our
panel today
[Applause]
so
may mister oil and thomas zuma
join me and i'm just going to catch you
in front of the stage
welcome
you have one microphone for the two of
you okay
so i'm going to start with you mr panna
what what you already have your phone in
your hand so you you wrote down some key
messages i guess well the major key
message is having two white male boomer
summarizing the uh diversity discussion
i would say sorry on that one but lucky
enough he's already also yeah yeah yeah
but let's face it that that that is the
status of our society yeah
so that's that's that's an easy
conclusion
on my point we had a lot of
small issues which i liked
starting from the bilingual one and
having
more more more courses for men than
women to train for for for the work
environment i guess these are
important things but let's start at the
beginning diversity there is a i always
think there is a very simple reason why
you want to have diversity it's ashby's
law of requisite
complexity it means if we have grand
challenges and complex problems and i
guess we have a lot of them
you need the corresponding diversity
and that means also the corresponding
diversity in the teams so that's that's
a very easy ex explanation why you need
diversity
so
little things i have to state here i'm
for the quarter and the the reason is
very easy we are we are too slow with
our culture changes and this is the only
leverage we have i would like to do it
by now i cannot because of legal reasons
i cannot enforce it although i would
like to do it and that is already the
major huddle to to to
to get over and i think everything else
could be achieved afterwards but as long
as we don't have this
we have trouble and the other there is
one final thing i i would point out
from the outside
my
my son was in colombia for for a student
exchange and from the outside germany
looks like heaven because we are a rich
country and we put already a lot of
money into international exchange but on
the other side if you look at the report
on the pact for fortune and innovation
there is having the best people but
there is nothing on internet
international there's no indicator on
that one and the final one
there is a site for gay
this site for ghee sorry this and shaft
cycles
everybody knows this in germany
that is a
is an that was the easy way out of
germany to get ri to to uh what did we
do we exchanged time in employment
to get out of the discussion for hiring
in science because hiring in science
means it's it's a exclusion process it's
a very difficult thing people have to
leave not everybody can have a permanent
position and these discussions are very
hurtful discussions and because the
system didn't want it we have this site
for gear because uh you have limited
resources and limit limited resources
means you will have a selection
and we we we were we
have chosen a very
uh lame
way you might say to get out of this and
this is this side for gay we could do
other even with a strong german laws on
employment we could do it in another way
but we don't want to have the
discussions
uh that that for young people uh uh this
kind of selection process so this is all
i had in one sentence what did you learn
what do you take home and what to you
transfer
this is actually
self similar uh uh
self similar recognition i took i i will
take home why the heck is not everything
in my institute in bilingual
because this is something this is so
stupid easy that you think why why why
do i have to sit here and and uh and uh
get this idea
but on the other side you might say this
coming from a man is a self-similar
recognition
thank you so much
mr summer what do you take home
i found the most important first of all
thank you to all of you who are
discussing here there was a great
discussion and i learned a lot but what
you said in the end
diversity is a matter of democracy i
think this is the most important
sentence for me which i take from this
discussion today so that was really um i
think it breaks down everything to this
really important point and uh one thing
that we started also with was the point
that
we're doing a lot at the institutes now
and i think science is also a little bit
living in a bubble so we are trying to
do much more about internalization
internationalization diversity than
maybe in other areas but still we forget
that people that work at our institutes
also have a life outside of the
the institute and here they are running
into into problems and we have to
provide help for that and this is
one thing which i also take with me
thank you so much and please just
because you're sitting in the back
please join me again francisco maling
noah
iwo nakafizka and luke damaster and
we say goodbye to our panel and with
that we invite you to the recep to just
join us to say goodbye and just like
one
time and yes thank you so much you go
over there yes
[Music]
you